before last night's invasion with bombs
and bullets cyber warfare was already
underway it took down government and
banking websites in ukraine and those
attacks were similar to other online
attacks that the u.s blamed on russia a
charge we should point out that russia
denies among just about everything in
this conflict with us now is virginia
senator mark warner chairman of the
senate select committee on intelligence
senator good morning to you
i share your compliments for the
intelligence community which really
nailed it they were precise they were
timely
what is unfolding there is exactly what
they said would unfold so with that in
mind where is this going
well i'm very worried about
the next couple of days
we see russia attacking all across
ukraine not just kiev and east but
literally in the west as well
i am concerned the earlier report about
our troops
on the polish border
processing refugees one of the things
that i'm gravely concerned about is if
russia unleashes its full cyber power
against ukraine once you put malware
into the wild in a sense
it knows no geographic boundaries so if
the russians decide they're going to try
to turn off the power
turn off all the electricity all across
ukraine very likely that may turn off
the power in eastern poland and east
romania that could affect our troops if
suddenly hospitals are shut down if
those nato troops american troops
somehow have a
car accident because the the stop lights
don't work
we are suddenly in an area of
hypothetically um an article 5 where one
nato country's attacked we all have to
come to each other's aid i'm also
worried as we and i applaud the
president for maintaining this strong
alliance it's not only we and nato but
it's countries all over the world are
condemning putin's
violence and and total disregard of any
kind of international norm in this
massive invasion of ukraine i know we in
our countries will
weigh in with all our sanctions that
could also generate an attack
you co-founded the senate cyber security
caucus no one knows that area like you
you mentioned it in the context of
ukraine should americans be bracing as
we dial up the sanctions on russia for
them to break into our space in cyber uh
warfare
i think everyone
should up their cyber defenses i mean
the challenge we have when we see cyber
sometime when you release malware into
the into a network you don't know where
it ends up about six years ago five
years ago there was an attack called not
petya russia launched against ukraine it
ended up hitting american european and
even russian assets cost billions of
dollars that was one piece of malware if
russia left a hundred pieces a thousand
pieces of malware out in an attack
against nato or even against ukraine
that might bleed into nato nations we
are in totally unpredictable territory
we are indeed senator mark warner thank
you very much i'm sure we'll have you
back on as this continues to unfold we
appreciate it
thank you